we've already talked about light having
wave-like properties and the waves that
we're familiar with in our everyday life
we consider to be disturbances traveling
through a medium we talked about
dropping a pebble in water and the water
is a medium and we see the wave travel
outwards we think about sound waves
which is a disturbance in the air we
think about we think about a wave
traveling through this rope the medium
there's the rope so in the mid 19th
century it was completely reasonable for
folks to say well look light has
wave-like properties it must be a
disturbance traveling through a medium
and they said well what do we call that
medium even though we don't observe it
directly well let's call it the
luminiferous ether
so an obvious question that was facing
folks who had this reasonable assumption
they said well how do we can we somehow
detect the luminiferous either can we
validate the luminiferous ether existing
and a key realization is as well
we must be moving quite rapidly relative
to the luminiferous ether how do we know
that
well we just have to remind ourselves
that obviously the earth is rotating but
not only is it rotating on its own axis
but it's rotating around the sun
and so if this is if this is the sun
right over here this is the earth
the earth is rotating and these are all
rough these are all rough figures the
earth is moving around the sun at
approximately 30 kilometers
per second
30 kilometers per second by our everyday
standards that's quite fast but we're
not done yet because the sun is also
moving around the center of the galaxy
and this isn't an actual picture of the
milky way obviously we haven't gotten
this far from our own galaxy to actually
get this type of a vantage point but if
the
if the sun were right over there the sun
estimates are are moving with a speed of
200 roughly 200
column you write that in a better color
so you can actually see it
200 kilometers per second
200
kilometers per second around the center
of the milky way and then the milky way
itself
could be moving so we don't know our
actual uh kind of
our orientation relative to the ether
but we are we're constantly changing our
orientation we're moving in these
orbital patterns if there is some type
of luminiferous ether
if there is some type of luminiferous
ether and i'm just going to draw these
lines over here to kind of show our
luminiferous ether we must be moving
relative to it if we orient ourselves
just the right way in fact the odds of
us being stationary relative to the
ether are pretty close to zero
especially if we wait a little if we're
stationary relative to the ether right
now let's say at this point since we're
changing our direction we're not going
to be stationary relative to the ether
at that point and that's just when you
consider the earth's orbit around the
sun it's even more true when you think
about the the solar system's orbit
around the center of the galaxy or even
the movement of the galaxy so we should
be moving relative to the ether or the
ether should be moving relative to us so
we should be able to detect some type of
some type of what's called an ether wind
because it should be moving relative
ether
wind
now how would you detect an ether wind
well let's think about some other type
of medium moving relative to us let's
say that we are
let's say that we are sitting on an
island
let's say that we are sitting on a let
me do this in a better color for an
island so let's say that we're in an
island that's in the middle of a stream
so these are the shores of the stream
these are the shores of the stream and
there is some type of a current so the
water is moving in that direction so
that's the that's the medium and now
let's start a wave propagating through
this so if i were to just take a pebble
and drop it right over here what would
happen well the wave is going to
propagate faster to the left than it is
to the right and this is from our
everyday experience and that's because
to the left it's moving the medium is
also moving to the left so as as the
media moves and then you propagate
through that medium you're going to move
faster to the left than to the right so
the wave is going to propagate is going
to propagate
something
is going to propagate so after a small
period of time the crest on the right
might be there but the crest on the left
might be there so it might look
something
something like this and then after
another period of time it might look
something
it'll look something
like this so the general point is for
this little stream example you're going
to see your wave propagate faster in the
direction of which the medium is moving
so similarly if you have an ether wind
if you have ether wind and this
luminiferous ether is the medium by
which the light propagates disturbance
the light is a disturbance in this
medium
then if this ether wind has some
let's say it has some speed
let's just call it s
if you were to
if you if light were to travel in if you
were to try to propagate light in that
direction
versus in
this direction
versus in that direction it should go
faster we should notice it going faster
if it's going along the same direction
as either because propagating through
something that's also moving relative to
us and likewise if it's going in the
opposite direction of the ether even
though it's propagating through the
actual ether at that same speed the
ether is moving in the other direction
so the light based on our 19th century
understanding of the universe the light
should seem slower so you can imagine
people started theorized well
maybe we can measure light in different
directions and see if relative to us if
relative to us we see a different
velocity for light now the problem was
is that in the mid 19th century light is
incredibly fast we now know that the
speed of light is approximately three
hundred thousand
three hundred thousand
kilometers
kilometers per second and in the mid
19th century we didn't have good tools
to measure this with a lot of with a lot
of accuracy
especially because the ether wind itself
even if you say hey this is 30
kilometers per second maybe we're moving
around the galaxy at you know 200
kilometers per second maybe 300
kilometers per second that's still a
small fraction of the actual speed of
light so if you don't have a lot of if
you don't have a lot of accuracy when
you're measuring the speed of light in
these different directions and the ether
wind is so slow relative to the speed of
light well with just traditional tools
in the 19th century you're not going to
be able to detect this actual ether wind
if it existed and that's what gets us to
the famous mickelson morley experiment
because there they didn't just directly
try to measure the speed of light in one
direction or another instead they
thought about well let's pop let's let's
let's split some light into two
different directions and then recombine
them and see the interference patterns
and if the different directions traveled
at different speeds then we'll have
different interference patterns and
we're going to see that in the next
video